- Bine ai revenit la „Înțelegerea Informației
și Computației Cuantice".
Numele meu este John Watrous și
sunt directorul tehnic pentru IBM Quantum Education.
Aceasta este a șasea lecție din serie și este a doua lecție din
a doua unitate a seriei, care tratează algoritmii cuantici.
În lecția anterioară, am discutat modelul
de interogare al computației și am văzut că în acel model, algoritmii cuantici pot
oferi un avantaj remarcabil
față de algoritmii clasici, inclusiv un avantaj exponențial în cazul problemei lui Simon.
Din păcate, modelul de
interogare nu are cu adevărat nicio relevanță practică
directă sau imediată.
Noțiunea de cutie neagră este o
abstractizare foarte utilă după cum se dovedește, dar avem ceva de
lucru dacă vrem să aplicăm
perspectivele pe care le-am
dobândit din modelul de interogare într-un cadru computațional mai standard, unde intrările sunt date ca șiruri de biți
mai degrabă decât ca oracole sau cutii negre.
Scopul principal al acestei lecții este să stabilim o fundație
de la care putem face asta.
Iată o privire de ansamblu asupra lecției. Pentru mare parte din lecție, ne vom concentra
pe costul computațional,
sau cu alte cuvinte, cât de dificile sunt diferitele
sarcini computaționale și cum putem măsura acea dificultate.
Aproximativ vorbind, asta se traduce prin cât timp trebuie să așteptăm
ca computațiile să se termine și, în ultimă instanță, ce
probleme computaționale
putem rezolva și care
sunt dincolo de capacitățile noastre.
Vom începe cu
câteva exemple. Factorizarea întreagă și calcularea celui mai mare divizor
comun sau CMMDC pe scurt.
Acestea sunt exemple foarte bune pentru ilustrarea
principiilor de bază și, de asemenea, ambele se întâmplă
să fie extrem de relevante pentru algoritmul lui Shor, pe care îl vom
discuta în lecția următoare,
deci vom obține efectiv
dublul randamentului din aceste exemple.
Apoi vom discuta noțiunea de cost computațional mai general și cum îl putem măsura.
Există multe
moduri diferite în care se poate face asta, dar ne vom concentra destul
de îngust pe cum putem face asta cu modele circuit ale computației,
mai specific circuit-uri Boolean
și circuit-uri cuantice.
Accentul va fi pe algoritmi, spre deosebire de hardware-ul
calculatoarelor, de exemplu, și vom fi mai preocupați
de cum scalează costurile
rulării unui algoritm pe măsură ce instanțele specifice de probleme pe care rulează cresc în dimensiune, mai degrabă
decât de câte secunde,
minute sau ore necesită o
anumită computație.
Ideea care motivează acest punct de vedere este că algoritmii au
importanță fundamentală.
Până în ziua de azi,
încă rulăm algoritmi care au fost dezvoltați cu
foarte, foarte mult timp în urmă și, în mod firesc, aceștia vor fi folosiți
pe instanțe de probleme din ce în ce
mai mari, folosind hardware din ce în ce mai rapid și mai fiabil pe măsură ce tehnologia se dezvoltă.
Și modul în care scalează ne spune multe
despre cât de utili sunt și cât de utili vor continua să fie.
În ultima secțiune a lecției, ne vom întoarce la o sarcină extrem de importantă, care este rularea computațiilor clasice
pe calculatoare cuantice. Motivul pentru care aceasta este importantă nu este că sperăm să înlocuim calculatoarele clasice
cu calculatoare cuantice,
ceea ce pare extrem de puțin probabil să se întâmple prea curând, dacă se va întâmpla vreodată, ci mai degrabă pentru că deschide
multe posibilități interesante
pentru algoritmii cuantici.
Mai specific, odată ce știm cum să rulăm computații clasice
pe calculatoare cuantice, acestea devin disponibile algoritmilor cuantici ca subrutine
deci putem valorifica efectiv
tot ce știm despre algoritmii clasici în urmărirea avantajelor computaționale cuantice.
Calculatoarele clasice pe care le avem astăzi sunt cu adevărat minuni ale tehnologiei.
Sunt incredibil de rapide, dar nu atât de rapide încât nicio problemă computațională
să nu fie dincolo de capacitățile lor.
Unele probleme computaționale
sunt atât de dificile în mod intrinsec încât, deși avem
algoritmi pentru a le rezolva, niciun calculator de pe Pământ astăzi
nu este suficient de rapid pentru a rula acești
algoritmi până la final pe intrări chiar și de dimensiuni moderate în decursul vieții unui om
sau chiar în decursul
vieții Pământului însuși.
Pentru a explica mai departe, să aruncăm o privire la
problema factorizării întregi.
Enunțul problemei este foarte simplu. Intrarea în problemă este un număr întreg N care este cel puțin doi, iar ieșirea este
factorizarea în numere prime a lui N,
și ceea ce înseamnă asta este o listă a factorilor primi ai lui N împreună cu puterile la care aceste numere prime trebuie ridicate
pentru a obține N prin
înmulțirea tuturor împreună.
Desigur, putem înmulți factorii primi în orice ordine, dar în afara ordinii lor,
factorizările în numere prime sunt întotdeauna unice pentru fiecare alegere a lui N.
Acel fapt se numește
teorema fundamentală a aritmeticii și dacă ești interesat
să afli mai multe despre ea, este ceva ce poți găsi
la începutul
multor cărți de teoria numerelor.
Ca un exemplu foarte simplu, iată factorizarea în numere prime
a numărului 12.
Este doi la puterea doi
înmulțit cu trei la puterea unu.
WEBVTT
Nu surprinzător, un
calculator îți poate spune asta într-o clipită, căutând
iterativ factori primi.
Iată un alt exemplu. Nu voi încerca să citesc acest număr.
Are aproximativ 3,4 quattuordecilioane, și trebuie să recunosc că mi se pare ciudat că există chiar și un astfel de nume,
dar oricum, are 46 de cifre zecimale și aici poți vedea
factorizarea sa în numere prime.
Un calculator poate să îți spună asta și pe asta. Am factorizat acest număr folosind metoda de factorizare inclusă în biblioteca de matematică simbolică
pentru Python,
și a durat câteva secunde, ceea ce nu este un timp deosebit de lung, dar a existat o întârziere vizibilă.
Și cu siguranță metoda factor N nu găsește această factorizare în numere prime căutând naiv factori primi.
De fapt, folosește o combinație
hibridă de algoritmi diferiți, inclusiv unul numit algoritmul colored row, care este un algoritm de factorizare
mai sofisticat decât căutarea naivă iterativă
a factorilor primi și, deși acel număr poate părea destul de mare,
ca intrare într-o problemă computațională, nu este chiar atât de mare.
Are doar 46 de caractere.
Iată încă un exemplu. Este un număr cu 309 cifre zecimale.
Dacă îl scriem în notație binară, are 1.024 de biți și de aceea se numește RSA1024.
Factorizarea în numere prime a acestui număr nu este cunoscută în prezent.
Acest număr provine din
provocarea de factorizare RSA, care a fost organizată de RSA
Laboratories din 1991 până în 2007.
Au oferit premii în bani
pentru factorizările în numere prime ale diferitelor numere de dimensiuni
din ce în ce mai mari, inclusiv acesta, care valora 100.000 USD,
dar acel premiu nu a fost niciodată colectat.
Securitatea sistemului de
criptografie cu cheie publică RSA se bazează pe dificultatea
factorizării întregi.
Dacă poți factoriza, poți
sparge sistemul, deci scopul provocării era practic să urmărească
stadiul artei în factorizare.
Concluzia este că
factorizarea acestui număr este dincolo de capacitățile noastre actuale.
Pe cât știm, problema
în sine este prea complexă pentru ca calculatoarele clasice
să o rezolve în practică.
Cel mai mare număr din provocarea RSA care a fost factorizat până acum, apropo, are 250 de cifre zecimale.
Ar putea fi puțin greu
de citit pe ecran, dar iată factorizarea în numere prime a lui RSA250.
A fost realizată în 2020 folosind un algoritm cunoscut sub numele de ciurul corpului de numere, și a fost un efort colectiv implicând zeci de mii
de calculatoare din întreaga lume.
Acum să considerăm o altă
problemă computațională, care este problema calculării celui mai mare
divizor comun, sau CMMDC pe scurt,
a două numere întregi nenegative.
Iată un enunț al problemei. Intrarea constă din două
numere de data aceasta, N și M,
și vom presupune că
nu sunt ambele egale cu zero.
Scopul este să calculăm
CMMDC-ul acestor două numere, care este cel mai mare număr întreg D care divide exact atât N cât și M,
și dacă te gândești la
factorizările în numere prime ale lui N și M, vei găsi că CMMDC este produsul tuturor numerelor prime
care divid atât N cât și M, ridicate la minimul puterilor care apar în cele două
factorizări în numere prime.
Deci este legat de problema
factorizării întregi, dar se dovedește că este mult, mult mai ușor
pentru calculatoare să rezolve. Putem calcula CMMDC-uri pentru numere cu mii de cifre
într-o clipită.
Este cam inutil să încerc să îți arăt exemple pe ecran, deoarece am putea umple
întregul ecran cu cifre și tot am descrie
instanțe ușor de rezolvat ale acestei probleme.
Dar dacă ești interesat, urmează linkul din descrierea videoclipului către pagina manualului pentru această lecție și vei găsi celule de cod
pentru tipurile de computații
despre care vorbesc, inclusiv unele care calculează
CMMDC-uri ale numerelor mari, și le poți încerca singur.
Întrebarea este de ce este posibil să calculezi CMMDC-uri atât de ușor?
Și răspunsul la această întrebare este că avem algoritmi eficienți
pentru a calcula CMMDC-uri.
Printre ei se numără algoritmul lui Euclid, care a fost descoperit cu mai mult de 2.000 de ani în urmă, dar există și alți
algoritmi CMMDC eficienți.
Și, desigur, vorbim despre algoritmi clasici aici, deci asta duce la o altă întrebare.
Ar putea exista un algoritm
clasic eficient pentru factorizarea întreagă
care să ne permită să factorizăm numere ca RSA1024
într-o clipită?
Și răspunsul este da. Absolut ar putea exista un algoritm clasic eficient
pentru factorizare și în prezent nu știm nicio modalitate
de a exclude acea posibilitate. Tot ce putem spune este că
nu am găsit unul încă.
Pentru toți algoritmii clasici
de factorizare pe care îi cunoaștem, încă în esență
căutăm factori
și asta pune numere ca
RSA1024 dincolo de capacitățile noastre.
Algoritmii eficienți CMMDC,
pe de altă parte, pur și simplu nu funcționează în acel mod.
Ei nu caută un
cel mai mare divizor comun. Îl construiesc efectiv cu o procedură mecanică cu un cost aproximativ comparabil
cu înmulțirea acelorași
două numere împreună, și voi mai spune câte ceva despre asta mai târziu în lecție.
WEBVTT
Desigur, toate acestea conduc
spre algoritmul lui Shor, pe care îl vom vedea în lecția următoare, care este un algoritm cuantic eficient
pentru calcularea factorizărilor în numere prime, dar mai avem un teren de acoperit înainte să ajungem acolo.
Urmează să vorbim
despre un cadru matematic prin care putem măsura costurile computaționale
ale diferiților algoritmi,
inclusiv unii despre care am discutat deja.
Pentru a fi clar, ne vom concentra foarte îngust pe circuit-uri, care este doar o mică parte
dintr-un subiect mult mai larg.
Să începem cu o privire de ansamblu la nivel înalt a unei computații obișnuite
din lecția anterioară, adică în special că nu ne gândim
la probleme de interogare,
ci ne gândim la
probleme unde intrarea este dată explicit ca un șir binar.
Cum am spus în lecția anterioară, am putea desigur să permitem
alte simboluri dacă am alege, dar să păstrăm lucrurile simple și să rămânem cu șiruri binare
atât pentru intrare cât și pentru ieșire.
Computația în sine ar putea fi modelată sau descrisă în diverse moduri, cum ar fi cu modelul
mașinii Turing al computației,
circuit-uri Boolean, circuit-uri cuantice, sau programe scrise în
un limbaj ca Python sau orice alt limbaj al alegerii tale.
Cum am spus cu puțin înainte, ne vom concentra pe
circuit-uri, Boolean și cuantice.
Mai întâi, să petrecem puțin mai mult timp vorbind despre intrare și ieșire, pe care le presupunem a fi șiruri binare.
Folosind șiruri binare, putem codifica multe tipuri diferite de
obiecte matematice, cum ar fi numere, vectori,
matrice, grafuri,
descrieri ale moleculelor, de exemplu, precum și liste ale tuturor acestor obiecte și ale altora.
Ca un exemplu foarte simplu, dacă vrem să codificăm numere întregi
nenegative ca șiruri binare, putem folosi notația binară.
Aici, în acest tabel, vei vedea primele 13
numere întregi nenegative împreună cu reprezentările sau codificările lor binare.
Aici, în a treia coloană, poți vedea lungimea
fiecăreia dintre aceste codificări, care este pur și simplu numărul total de biți de care ai nevoie pentru codificare,
și iată o formulă simplă care îți spune exact câți biți
sunt necesari în general pentru orice număr întreg nenegativ N.
Observă în special că
lungimea codificării este în general mult mai mică
decât numărul în sine.
Este logaritmică în număr.
RSA1024, de exemplu, are o codificare cu lungimea 1.024, dar numărul în sine este
desigur mult mai mare decât atât.
Această schemă de codificare funcționează
pentru numere întregi nenegative, dar dacă vrem să gestionăm
numere întregi arbitrare, inclusiv cele negative, putem
pur și simplu adăuga un bit de semn.
Putem de asemenea permite oricâți zerouri de conducere în aceste codificări dacă vrem ca codificările
să umple un bloc de biți sau un registru de dimensiune fixă
atâta timp cât este suficient de mare. Uneori aceasta este foarte convenabil.
Aceasta nu este singura modalitate de a codifica numere întregi ca șiruri de biți.
Există alte modalități de a face asta, dar aceasta este o
modalitate destul de standard.
Pentru alte tipuri de obiecte care ar putea forma intrările sau ieșirile problemelor computaționale de care suntem interesați, putem elabora
alte scheme de codificare.
De exemplu, gândește-te la cum
ai putea codifica un vector sau un graf ca un șir binar sau gândește-te la cum ai putea codifica
două șiruri binare într-un
singur șir binar folosind doar simbolul zero și unu, fără spațiu sau orice alt simbol
pentru a separa cele două șiruri. Există cu siguranță modalități de
a face aceste lucruri și, de fapt, avem multă libertate
cu privire la exact cum le facem.
Adesea nu va exista o singură modalitate standard sau universal acceptată de a codifica orice lucru despre care vorbim
ca un șir binar,
dar asta e în regulă, putem alege una sau putem inventa una nouă dacă preferăm.
Dintr-un punct de vedere pur formal, ne gândim la computații ca la transformări în esență mecanice pe șiruri de biți
și specificul oricăror
scheme de codificare pe care le folosim este cu siguranță important la un anumit nivel.
Dar cu toate acestea, atunci când proiectăm și
analizăm algoritmi, de obicei nu ne îngrijorăm prea mult de specificul
schemelor de codificare.
Dacă ceri la doi oameni diferiți să elaboreze o modalitate de a codifica, să zicem, molecule de un anumit
tip ca șiruri binare,
te-ai putea aștepta să elaboreze modalități diferite de a face asta, dar dacă aceștia erau oameni rezonabili care știau ce făceau,
te-ai putea de asemenea să te aștepți în mod rezonabil că ar fi un proces computațional destul de
simplu să traduci înainte și înapoi între cele două scheme de codificare,
cel mai probabil necesitând o computație foarte
simplă care ar fi destul de ușoară în comparație cu computația reală
de care suntem interesați.
Concluzia este că detaliile privind schemele de codificare pe care le folosim sunt adesea destul de secundare și accentul nostru este pe
algoritmii înșiși.
Nimic din toate acestea nu va fi o problemă pentru această lecție, apropo. Ne vom concentra în principal pe probleme care privesc numere întregi, pe care le vom presupune codificate în binar,
dar este ceva de care trebuie să fii conștient.
În general, pentru orice tip de problemă despre care vorbim, lungimea intrării se referă
la numărul de biți de care avem nevoie pentru a codifica intrarea,
și privim lungimea intrării ca fiind dimensiunea instanței oricărei probleme la care ne gândim.
Acum să considerăm
computația în sine, care este reprezentată de
dreptunghiul albastru din această figură.
Modul în care vom măsura
costul acestei computații este să numărăm numărul de operații elementare pe care le necesită.
Intuitiv vorbind, o operație elementară este una care implică un număr mic și fix
de biți sau qubit-uri
care pot fi efectuate rapid și ușor, cum ar fi calcularea AND-ului
a doi biți, de exemplu.
WEBVTT
La nivel formal,
există diferite modalități de a defini ce este o operație elementară, în funcție de
modelul computațional pe care îl folosim.
De exemplu, o operație elementară ar putea fi un pas al unei mașini Turing dacă am folosi acel model.
În scopurile acestei lecții, ne vom concentra pe modele circuit, cum am precizat deja, și mai specific pe circuit-urile
cuantice și Boolean.
Când lucrăm cu circuit-uri, este tipic să ne gândim la fiecare gate ca reprezentând o operație elementară.
Am văzut mai multe gate-uri cuantice diferite până acum în serie,
inclusiv gate-uri X, Y și Z, gate-uri Hadamard, gate-uri S și T,
gate-uri NOT controlate, gate-uri swap, gate-uri Toffoli și gate-uri Fredkin.
Am vorbit și despre gate-uri de interogare în contextul modelului de interogare, dar nu vom lucra în modelul de interogare în această lecție, deci nu ne vom îngrijora
de gate-urile de interogare deocamdată.
Am văzut de asemenea că orice operație unitară pe orice număr de qubit-uri
poate fi privită ca un gate dacă vrem să facem asta.
În scopurile măsurării costului, totuși, asta nu va fi foarte util, deci ce vom face este să alegem pur și simplu un set de gate-uri
și vom privi acel set ca fiind setul nostru de operații elementare.
Mai întâi, vom include
gate-urile unitare cu un singur qubit pe care le vezi aici,
adică gate-urile X, Y și Z,
gate-uri Hadamard și gate-uri S și T, precum și inversele lor
sau transpusele conjugate.
Nu avem nevoie de toate aceste gate-uri. De îndată ce avem gate-uri Hadamard și T, le putem implementa pe celelalte,
dar doar de dragul convenienței, le vom include pe toate.
Vom include de asemenea gate-uri NOT controlate, și acestea vor fi singurele
gate-uri cu mai mulți qubit-uri din setul nostru.
Și în final, vom include măsurători în baza standard cu un singur qubit, astfel încât să putem obține efectiv informații clasice
care să iasă din circuit-urile noastre.
Dacă ne concentrăm doar pe gate-urile unitare și uităm de
măsurători pentru un moment, obținem ceea ce se numește
un set universal de gate-uri.
Ceea ce înseamnă asta este că
orice operație unitară pe orice număr de qubit-uri poate
fie să fie implementată exact
fie arbitrar de aproape
cu un circuit cuantic construit din aceste gate-uri.
Cu alte cuvinte, acesta este un
set de gate-uri suficient de bun pentru a construi orice operație unitară
din ele.
Nu neapărat exact, dar putem obține o aproximare la fel de bună cum vrem.
Asta ar putea necesita multe gate-uri și nu este chiar greu de raționat că trebuie să necesite uneori
multe gate-uri,
dar cu toate acestea, este întotdeauna posibil.
Nu este un lucru simplu să dovedești că acesta este un set universal de gate-uri, deși, și nu vom discuta cum
se face asta în serie,
dar este un fapt destul de bine cunoscut și există de fapt diferite
modalități în care poate fi dovedit.
Există și alte seturi de gate-uri care sunt uneori folosite
în locul acestuia, cum ar fi gate-uri Toffoli, gate-uri Hadamard și gate-uri S în plus față de măsurători,
dar aceasta este o alegere destul de standard.
Deci, în rezumat, acestea sunt
operațiile cuantice pe care le vom privi ca elementare.
Pentru circuit-urile Boolean,
vom considera aceste patru gate-uri ca
operații elementare: gate-uri AND, gate-uri OR, gate-uri NOT și FANOUT.
FANOUT, apropo, nu este
întotdeauna numărat ca gate, dar va fi
important pentru noi să facem asta, cum vom vedea mai târziu în lecție.
Similar cu ce am avut pentru
setul nostru standard de gate-uri cuantice, acest set este puțin redundant.
Nu ai nevoie de ambele AND și OR. Poți crea oricare dintre ele folosind celălalt cu trei gate-uri NOT,
dar nu strică să le incluzi pe ambele și este pur și simplu convenabil.
Cum poate știi deja, acesta este un set universal de gate-uri
pentru computații deterministe, adică orice funcție
de la biți la biți
poate fi implementată cu un circuit Boolean compus din gate-uri din această colecție.
Din nou, la fel cum am
avut pentru circuit-urile cuantice, asta nu înseamnă că orice funcție poate fi implementată eficient
de un circuit Boolean,
și într-adevăr, cele mai multe funcții
pot fi implementate numai cu circuit-uri foarte mari
din simpla motivație că există foarte, foarte multe funcții
și nu toate pot avea circuit-uri mici. Pur și simplu nu sunt suficiente
circuit-uri mici disponibile.
Universalitatea este mai ușor
de dovedit în acest caz decât în cazul cuantic după cum se dovedește.
Deci, dacă nu știi deja
cum să o dovedești, gândește-te și
vezi dacă poți să îți dai seama dacă ești dispus.
Acum că am decis care
gate-uri le vom permite și pe care le vom considera
operații elementare, putem să ne gândim câte dintre ele
sunt necesare pentru a efectua
diverse computații.
Pentru a face asta, vom folosi
această definiție pentru dimensiunea unui circuit.
Această definiție funcționează atât pentru
circuit-urile Boolean cât și pentru cele cuantice și este foarte simplă.
Dimensiunea unui circuit este
numărul total de gate-uri pe care le are.
De exemplu, dacă revenim
la același exemplu pe care l-am văzut de mai multe ori, care este circuitul nostru Boolean pentru calcularea SAU exclusiv a doi biți,
vedem că are dimensiunea șapte
deoarece există șapte gate-uri, două gate-uri FANOUT, două gate-uri NOT,
două gate-uri AND și un gate OR. Dacă am decide să nu numărăm
gate-urile FANOUT, ceea ce este comun, ar avea dimensiunea egală cu cinci,
dar noi vom număra gate-urile FANOUT, deci dimensiunea sa este șapte.
WEBVTT
Dimensiunea unui circuit
corespunde numărului de operații elementare
pe care trebuie să le efectuăm.
Deci, dacă am efectua
acele operații secvențial, dimensiunea ne-ar spune
cât timp ar dura,
deci te poți gândi la dimensiunea circuitului ca reprezentând timpul de rulare secvențial.
Aceasta va fi modul în care vom
măsura costul computațional în scopurile acestei lecții.
Există o altă proprietate
a circuit-urilor care poate fi de asemenea privită ca timpul
necesar pentru a rula un circuit, și anume adâncimea circuitului.
Mai precis, adâncimea
este numărul maxim de gate-uri întâlnite pe orice cale de la un fir de intrare la un fir de ieșire,
ceea ce este echivalent cu numărul de straturi de gate-uri de care avem nevoie
pentru a crea circuitul, unde un strat se referă la un grup de gate-uri
care ar putea fi efectuate simultan deoarece nu au
niciun fir în comun.
De exemplu, circuitul nostru
de mai devreme are adâncimea patru și putem vedea direct din diagramă că există patru straturi.
Gate-urile FANOUT pot fi
efectuate simultan, gate-urile NOT pot fi
efectuate simultan și gate-urile AND pot fi
de asemenea efectuate simultan.
Deci ne putem gândi la adâncimea circuitului ca reprezentând timpul de rulare paralel.
Adâncimea circuitului este cu siguranță o noțiune interesantă și importantă și există câteva tehnici foarte
sofisticate care pot fi folosite pentru a reduce
adâncimea necesară pentru unele computații, uneori destul de dramatic, de fapt, dar este un subiect avansat
și nu vom mai spune prea multe despre el în această serie.
Deci, din nou, vom
măsura costul computațional în termeni de dimensiunea
circuitului sau, cu alte cuvinte,
numărul de operații elementare necesare pentru a efectua o computație.
La începutul lecției, am vorbit despre problema
factorizării întregi și am văzut că timpul necesar pentru un algoritm să rezolve această problemă
poate crește pe măsură ce intrările cresc în lungime, și aceasta este de obicei
problema pe care ne concentrăm
când analizăm algoritmi.
Adică suntem interesați de cum scalează costurile rulării algoritmilor pe măsură ce intrările devin din ce în ce mai mari.
Desigur, acest tip de scalare nu este singurul lucru care contează.
De exemplu, am putea fi pur și simplu interesați să găsim factorii
lui RSA1024 și atât.
Deci, într-un caz ca acela, am vorbi despre o
singură instanță a problemei unde nimic nu crește.
Dar când ne gândim la algoritmi, modul în care scalează costurile lor
contează foarte mult și ne spune multe
despre algoritmi.
Acest punct de vedere este
consistent cu ideea că algoritmii sunt fundamentali și, cum am vorbit mai devreme,
pe măsură ce trece timpul și tehnologia avansează, ei vor fi folosiți împotriva
intrărilor din ce în ce mai mari.
Dar observă că, în timp ce intrările problemelor computaționale
pot crește în dimensiune, circuit-urile nu cresc.
Fiecare circuit are o dimensiune fixă.
Și din acel motiv, dacă vrem să descriem un
algoritm folosind circuit-uri, de fapt vom avea nevoie de o familie de circuit-uri pentru a face asta,
și prin familie de circuit-uri, înțelegem o colecție de circuit-uri care devine din ce în ce mai mare, astfel încât să putem acomoda intrările
pe măsură ce devin din ce în ce mai mari. De exemplu, să considerăm un algoritm clasic determinist
pentru problema factorizării întregi, poate unul bazat pe diviziunea prin trial, dar specificul nu contează cu adevărat
pentru scopurile acestui exemplu.
Am putea în principiu
să descriem un astfel de algoritm folosind o familie de circuit-uri Boolean, unde dacă vrem să factorizăm un număr
a cărui reprezentare binară are N biți, luăm circuitul CN din familia noastră și introducem numărul
pe care vrem să-l factorizăm
în biții de intrare ai acelui circuit.
Uneori am putea alege să parametrizăm aceste
circuit-uri în moduri diferite, deci ar putea să nu fie întotdeauna cazul că al N-lea circuit are N biți de intrare,
dar aceasta este o modalitate destul de tipică de a face asta. În mod natural, pe măsură ce lungimile intrărilor devin mai lungi, ne-am aștepta ca circuit-urile
din această familie să devină mai mari
reflectând faptul că
factorizarea numerelor de patru biți este mult mai ușoară decât factorizarea numerelor de 1.024 biți, de exemplu.
Și deci, cu asta în minte, măsurăm costul unui astfel de
algoritm printr-o funcție, care ne spune câte
operații elementare
avem nevoie pentru fiecare posibilă lungime a intrării și putem face asta atât pentru algoritmii clasici cât și pentru cei cuantici.
Ca exemplu, să considerăm problema adunării întregi, care este cu siguranță mult
mai simplă decât factorizarea
sau chiar calcularea CMMDC-urilor.
Pentru a păstra lucrurile simple, să presupunem că atât N cât și
M sunt numere întregi nenegative și că sunt reprezentate
prin șiruri binare cu aceeași lungime.
Cum am putea construi circuit-uri Boolean care să adune aceste două numere împreună?
Ei bine, să începem cu un algoritm, algoritmul standard pentru adunare, care este analogul în baza doi al metodei
pe care presupun că cu toții am învățat-o pentru adunarea numerelor împreună cu
un creion și o hârtie, deci începem cu
biții cei mai puțin semnificativi,
îi adunăm împreună și asta ne dă bitul
cel mai puțin semnificativ al rezultatului împreună cu un bit de transport
pe care trebuie să-l considerăm
când trecem la poziția următoare. Și continuăm să trecem prin biți, generând biți de ieșire
împreună cu biți de transport
până când ajungem la final.
WEBVTT
Această metodă poate fi
exprimată destul de direct în termeni de circuit-uri Boolean.
O modalitate de a te gândi la asta este să începi cu un circuit mic pentru adunarea a două numere întregi de un singur bit împreună.
Asta ne va da un număr
între zero și doi, unde bitul mai puțin semnificativ este XOR-ul biților de intrare
și bitul mai semnificativ, sau bitul de transport dacă preferi, este AND-ul celor doi biți de intrare.
Uneori ne referim la un circuit care efectuează aceste
două operații împreună ca un half adder (semi-sumator).
Asta funcționează bine când
sunt doar doi biți de intrare, dar dacă vrem să adunăm împreună numere întregi cu mai mult de un singur bit fiecare,
va trebui să gestionăm
cumva biții de transport.
Deci ce putem face este să înlănțuim
două half adder-e împreună și să luăm OR-ul biților de transport pe care îi produc pentru a crea ceea ce se numește un full adder (sumator complet),
care este practic un circuit Boolean pentru adunarea a trei numere întregi de
un singur bit împreună.
Și odată ce avem un full adder, putem aduna numerele împreună
pur și simplu prin înlănțuire, procedând de la bitul cel mai puțin semnificativ
la bitul cel mai semnificativ. Practic implementăm algoritmul standard de adunare folosind full adder-ele pentru a
gestiona biții de transport.
Deci care este costul acestei computații?
Ei bine, avem nevoie de șapte gate-uri elementare
pentru fiecare gate XOR, ceea ce înseamnă 10 gate-uri pentru un half adder
și prin urmare 21 de gate-uri pentru un full adder, care este două half adder-e plus un gate OR.
Deci, la final, dacă numerele noastre de intrare au ambele AND biți, avem nevoie de un half adder pentru
bitul cel mai puțin semnificativ
și un full adder pentru fiecare alt bit, iar rezultatul final este 21 ori N minus unu plus 10 sau 21 N minus 11 gate-uri în total.
Dacă am decide din vreun motiv că nu vrem
să numărăm gate-urile FANOUT și am include gate-urile XOR
în setul nostru de gate-uri, am avea nevoie de cinci N minus
trei gate-uri în total.
Este bine să știi exact câte gate-uri sau operații elementare sunt necesare pentru a efectua diferite computații,
cum am văzut tocmai cu adunarea întreagă.
Și, desigur, dacă vrem de fapt să implementăm aceste computații, trebuie să cunoaștem aceste detalii.
Dar dacă mergem întotdeauna în atâtea detalii, mai ales pentru
algoritmi mai complicați, vom fi rapid îngropați în detalii
care în multe cazuri au
importanță secundară.
O modalitate de a simplifica lucrurile, care este foarte comună în
analiza algoritmilor, este să folosim notația big-O,
care ne permite să exprimăm
și să comparăm ratele de creștere într-un mod destul de simplu
care este foarte convenabil.
Și aici poți vedea definiția care stă la baza acestei notații.
Să presupunem că avem
două funcții G și H, pe care le putem gândi ca luând valori de numere întregi nenegative pentru simplitate,
deși aceasta nu este de fapt necesar. Poate G și H reprezintă costurile diferitelor computații, de exemplu.
Spunem atunci că G este big-O din H, care se scrie în mod tradițional
cu un semn egal ca acesta.
Dacă G de N este cel mult o
constantă pozitivă C ori H de N, atâta timp cât N este suficient de mare.
Deci aceasta este despre ce
se întâmplă când N devine mare.
Formal, ceea ce înseamnă „suficient de mare" este că există o alegere a lui N zero astfel încât inegalitatea este adevărată
de fiecare dată când N este cel puțin N zero.
Cheia este că aceste
numere C și N zero sunt fixe.
Pot fi orice numere,
dar oricare ar fi ele, nu pot schimba pe măsură ce N crește.
Dacă nu ai văzut
niciodată acest tip de definiție înainte, ar putea dura ceva să te obișnuiești cu ea și poți găsi resurse
care vor explica acest concept
în mult mai multe detalii
decât pot eu în această lecție.
De obicei, ceea ce facem este să alegem
funcția H să fie simplă pentru a exprima ceva despre cât de rapid crește funcția G.
De exemplu, funcția a cărei valoare este 17 ori N cub minus 257
ori N pătrat plus
65.537 este big-O din N cub și poți potrivi
acest exemplu la definiție
alegând C și N zero în mod corespunzător.
De exemplu, dacă luăm C egal cu 18, atunci vom avea că
expresia este într-adevăr cel mult 18 ori N cub
atâta timp cât N este suficient de mare.
Legând această notație înapoi la
exemplul adunării întregi, ceea ce putem spune acum este că există o familie de circuit-uri Boolean
pentru adunarea numerelor întregi nenegative împreună, astfel încât dimensiunea circuitului N, adică cel care funcționează
pentru intrări de lungime N
este big-O din N. Dimensiunea reală a lui CN
conform analizei noastre era 21 ori N minus 11,
dar aceea este big-O din N.
Acum nu este întotdeauna înțelept să arunci detalii ca acestea, dar aici are sens
deoarece dezvăluie natura esențială a algoritmului standard de adunare, care este că costul său scalează liniar
în dimensiunea numerelor
pe care le adunăm împreună, și această expresie nu este sensibilă la unele detalii de nivel scăzut ale modelului nostru,
cum ar fi exact care gate-uri considerăm că sunt operații elementare.
De exemplu, dacă am decide că gate-urile XOR ar trebui să fie considerate ca
operații elementare sau că gate-urile FANOUT nu ar trebui
să conteze ca gate-uri sau ambele,
tot am avea că adunarea întreagă poate fi calculată la costul big-O din N.
WEBVTT
Iată un alt exemplu de
problemă computațională, înmulțirea numerelor întregi.
Similar cu adunarea, putem întreba care este costul
al acestei computații.
Dacă considerăm algoritmul standard
de înmulțire, adică analogul în baza doi al metodei de înmulțire a numerelor
predate în școlile elementare,
care este practic
deplasare și adunare când lucrăm cu numere în binar, găsim că există circuit-uri Boolean cu dimensiunea big-O din N pătrat
pentru înmulțirea numerelor întregi de N biți.
Nu voi trece prin acesta în detaliu. Desigur, circuit-urile sunt
puțin mai complicate decât cele pentru adunare, dar dacă te gândești la modul în care
funcționează algoritmul standard
de înmulțire, nu ar trebui să fie surprinzător.
În esență, trebuie să
efectuăm aproximativ N adunări, fiecare cu cost liniar, și deci ajungem cu
cost pătratic în total.
Aceasta poate fi generalizată. Dacă unul dintre numere are N biți și celălalt are N biți, atunci avem nevoie de circuit-uri de
dimensiunea big-O din N ori M.
Aici, apropo, folosim de fapt o extensie a notației big-O unde avem mai multe variabile, dar poate fi extinsă astfel,
și dacă ești interesat
de detaliile specifice, te voi îndruma către conținutul manualului
pentru lecție, care din nou este legat în
descrierea videoclipului.
Este de fapt posibil
să înmulțești împreună două numere întregi de N biți într-un mod
care este asimptotic superior algoritmului standard de înmulțire.
În particular, algoritmul de înmulțire Schonhage-Strassen
înmulțește două numere întregi de N biți cu un cost de big-O din
N ori lungimea lui N
ori lungimea lungimii lui N. Deci pe măsură ce N devine mare, cum ar fi
zeci de mii de biți,
aceasta este de fapt o modalitate mai
eficientă de înmulțire, dar este complicată și suprasolicitarea o face impractică
pentru numerele mai mici.
Deci să adăugăm înmulțirea
la lista noastră de exemple.
Și pentru simplitate, să listăm costul dat de algoritmul standard de înmulțire, care este big-O din N pătrat.
Deci din nou, ne concentrăm pe natura esențială a acestui cost, care este că scalează pătratic
sau sub-pătratic dacă folosim metode asimptotic superioare.
Putem de asemenea considera
problema împărțirii întregi, care este enunțată precis pe ecran.
Aici vorbim despre calcularea unui cât și a unui rest, deci răspunsul constă
din două numere întregi, Q și R.
Din nou, există un algoritm standard
de împărțire și are de asemenea cost pătratic și, ca înmulțirea,
există de fapt algoritmi
asimptotic superiori.
Deci cum se compară algoritmii CMMDC?
Ei bine, algoritmul lui Euclid se dovedește
că are cost pătratic și asta am vrut să spun
mai devreme în lecție când am spus că putem calcula CMMDC-uri
la aproximativ același cost ca înmulțirea a două numere împreună.
Din nou, există
algoritmi asimptotic superiori pe linii similare cu
adunarea și înmulțirea,
deși costul este puțin
mai mare în acest caz, cel puțin pe cât știm.
Voi menționa doar încă un exemplu de problemă de adăugat la această listă, și anume exponențierea modulară.
Aici există trei numere
de intrare, K, M și N, iar scopul este să calculăm
N la puterea K modulo-M,
ceea ce înseamnă restul
după ce împărțim la M.
Nu este deloc evident, dar putem calcula exponențierea modulară la cost qubit, adică big-O din N cub
pentru numere întregi de N biți.
Modalitatea de a face asta nu este să calculăm mai întâi N la puterea K și apoi să calculăm restul.
Chiar și scrierea lui N la puterea K ar putea necesita exponențial de mulți biți, deci acea abordare nu va funcționa.
În schimb, putem folosi un algoritm
numit algoritmul puterii, care se mai numește și pătrate repetate, unde totul este făcut modulo-M
și folosim biții lui
K pentru a pătrata și înmulți iterativ într-un mod
care face totul să funcționeze.
Deci acesta este mai
costisitor decât celelalte, dar putem totuși efectua
exponențierea modulară destul de rapid pentru numere
cu mii de biți.
Deci cum se compară costurile acestor sarcini cu factorizarea întreagă?
Dacă începem simplu și
ne gândim la diviziunea prin trial, unde verificăm mai întâi dacă doi este un factor al numărului de intrare
și apoi verificăm trei și așa mai departe, vom ajunge cu un algoritm destul de
costisitor, big-O din N pătrat ori
doi la puterea N pe doi.
Fiecare împărțire durează timp pătratic și în cel mai rău caz, va trebui să căutăm factori primi până la rădăcina pătrată a numărului de intrare,
și de acolo vine N
pe doi. Dacă nu am găsit un
factor prim în acel punct, putem opri pentru că atunci
numărul de intrare în sine trebuie să fie prim.
Acesta este extrem de costisitor deoarece N apare ca exponent în această expresie, adică acest
algoritm are cost exponențial.
În contrast, toate exemplele pe care le avem în această casetă au ceea ce numim cost polinomial, unde N este ridicat la o putere,
dar acea putere este întotdeauna un număr fix care nu crește pe măsură
ce lungimea intrării crește.
În aceste cazuri, puterile
sunt unu, doi și trei.
Voi reveni la costul polinomial față de cel exponențial imediat, dar mai întâi, să terminăm
ce știm despre factorizare.
WEBVTT
Mai devreme am menționat
ciurul corpului de numere, care este cel mai bun
algoritm de factorizare pe care îl avem în termeni de modul în care scalează costul său.
De fapt, costul acestui algoritm nu este riguros dovedit deoarece este conectat cu unele întrebări deschise despre teoria numerelor,
dar se conjecturează că are
un cost care arată astfel.
De data aceasta big-O este în exponent, dar voi lăsa
acel detaliu la o parte.
Concluzia cheie este că este semnificativ mai bun
decât diviziunea prin trial deoarece, deși N apare în exponent,
este ridicat la puterea 1/3 și asta se traduce la un cost mult mai mic și de aceea algoritmul acesta
poate gestiona numere ca RSA250, în timp ce diviziunea prin trial
cu siguranță nu poate.
Este totuși exponențial în sensul că o putere a lui N apare într-un exponent și, drept rezultat,
tot nu poate gestiona
numere ca RSA1024.
Acum permiteți-mi să spun puțin mai mult despre costul polinomial
față de cel exponențial.
Spunem că un algoritm
are cost polinomial dacă costul său este big-O din N la puterea B,
unde B poate fi orice număr pozitiv, dar cheia este că B trebuie să fie fix, adică să nu schimbe
pe măsură ce lungimea intrării N crește.
Pentru exemplele pe care le-am văzut cu puțin înainte, adică adunarea întreagă, înmulțirea, împărțirea, calcularea CMMDC-urilor
și exponențierea modulară,
am avut că B era fie
unu, doi sau trei.
Deci acestea sunt toate
algoritmi cu cost polinomial.
Dar când spunem cost
polinomial mai general, B ar putea fi orice număr pozitiv.
Ar putea fi chiar un milion,
dar trebuie să fie fix.
Ca o abstractizare foarte grosieră, algoritmii cu cost polinomial
sunt de obicei priviți ca reprezentând algoritmi eficienți.
Este cu siguranță o simplificare excesivă, dar ca o orientare grosieră, te poți gândi la un
algoritm cu cost polinomial
ca utilizând cumva
structura unei probleme pentru a construi o soluție, spre deosebire de o abordare de tip forță brută
sau o căutare exhaustivă
peste un spațiu foarte mare.
Desigur, un algoritm al cărui cost scalează ca N la un milion
pe intrări de lungime N
nu ar fi privit în mod rezonabil
ca eficient și nu ne-am aștepta să
îl putem rula pe intrări mari.
Dar chiar și un algoritm N la
un milion trebuie să facă ceva inteligent care cumva reflectă structura
oricărei probleme pe care o rezolvă pentru a evita scalarea exponențială a costului care ar fi asociată cu
o căutare exhaustivă peste un domeniu mare.
Și în practică, identificarea unui algoritm cu cost polinomial este cu adevărat doar un prim
pas spre eficiență.
Dacă o problemă este importantă
și cineva descoperă primul algoritm cu cost
polinomial pentru ea, poate cu un exponent foarte mare,
poți fi destul de sigur că proiectanții de algoritmi
vor găsi îmbunătățiri care vor face acel exponent să scadă.
În esență, poți
te gândi la existența unui algoritm cu cost
polinomial pentru o problemă ca demonstrând fezabilitatea
rezolvării acelei probleme
pe intrări rezonabil de mari, dar ar putea exista totuși mult de lucru pentru a atinge o eficiență reală.
În teoria complexității, este tipic să spunem că costul unui algoritm
scalează sub-exponențial dacă costul este big-O din doi la puterea N
la puterea epsilon pentru fiecare număr real pozitiv epsilon și dacă nu este sub-exponențial,
atunci este exponențial, sau ar putea fi chiar super-exponențial ca doi la doi la N,
care este dublu exponențial,
dar atâta timp cât ieșirea
nu este super-exponențial de lungă, fiecare problemă poate fi de fapt
calculată de un circuit Boolean
cu cost exponențial după cum se dovedește. Deci distincția importantă aici este între costul polinomial
și cel exponențial.
Nu cunoaștem niciun algoritm clasic cu cost sub-exponențial pentru
factorizarea întreagă.
De exemplu, costul ciurului corpului de numere nu este big-O din doi la
N la epsilon când epsilon este 1/3 sau mai mic,
deci nu satisface această definiție.
Este fără îndoială un algoritm foarte inteligent, dar este totuși un ciur și efectiv tot căutăm
peste un spațiu foarte mare pentru a identifica factorii unui număr dat.
Cum vom vedea în lecția următoare, există de fapt un algoritm cuantic cu cost
polinomial pentru factorizarea întreagă.
Algoritmul lui Shor are cost polinomial și mai specific are cost qubit, similar cu exponențierea modulară.
O altă clasă de probleme cu care
poate ești familiarizat este clasa problemelor NP-complete.
Nu voi intra în ce sunt problemele NP-complete în această lecție, dar le poți căuta
dacă ești interesat.
Se conjecturează că
niciuna dintre aceste probleme nu are cost sub-exponențial.
Aceasta este în esență o versiune bazată pe circuit a ceea ce se numește uneori
ipoteza timpului exponențial, dar până acum nimeni nu a reușit
să dovedească asta.
De fapt, nici măcar nu putem dovedi că nu există algoritmi cu cost liniar pentru problemele NP-complete.
Este pur și simplu cu adevărat greu, cel
puțin pe cât știm, să excludem posibilitatea
unei descoperiri viitoare a unui algoritm incredibil de creativ
pentru aceste probleme.
WEBVTT
Iată o figură care
ilustrează relația dintre costul polinomial și cel exponențial.
Pe axa X avem lungimea intrării pentru orice problemă la care ne gândim, iar axa Y reprezintă
costul rezolvării acelei probleme
sau te poți gândi
la asta ca la timpul necesar pentru a rezolva problema dacă preferi.
Un algoritm cu cost exponențial
ar putea scala astfel.
Pentru intrări scurte, costul ar putea să nu fie deosebit de mare, cum ar fi factorizarea
numărului 12, de exemplu,
dar pe măsură ce lungimea intrării devine mai lungă, costul va exploda în cele din urmă.
Un algoritm cu cost polinomial,
pe de altă parte, ar putea avea o scalare care arată astfel.
Costul va crește totuși în general pe măsură ce intrările devin mai lungi și ar putea chiar costa mai mult decât algoritmul cu cost exponențial pentru unele intrări,
dar în cele din urmă va fi
mult mai puțin costisitor decât algoritmul cu cost exponențial și nu explodează
în același mod extrem
cum o fac algoritmii cu cost exponențial.
Deci, dacă ne imaginăm că
avem un cost maxim pe care suntem dispuși să îl cheltuim sau o durată maximă de timp pe care suntem dispuși să o așteptăm pentru un răspuns,
dacă preferi să te gândești în termeni de timp, atunci algoritmul cu cost exponențial va funcționa numai pentru intrări
până la o anumită lungime,
în timp ce, în general, algoritmul
cu cost polinomial ne va permite să rezolvăm
problema pentru intrări mai mari.
Și de aceea, de exemplu, putem calcula cu ușurință CMMDC-uri pentru numere cu mii de
biți, dar în cel mai rău caz,
nu putem factoriza numere de această dimensiune.
În ultima parte a lecției, ne vom întoarce atenția la implementarea computațiilor clasice
pe calculatoare cuantice.
Mai specific, vom
vedea că orice computație care poate fi efectuată de un circuit Boolean poate fi efectuată și de un circuit cuantic
la aproximativ același cost. Mai mult, aceasta poate fi
făcută într-un mod curat care este important dacă
vrem să rulăm aceste computații
ca subrutine în cadrul
unor computații cuantice mai mari și voi explica ce înțeleg prin curat când vom intra mai departe în discuție.
Vom folosi
gate-uri Toffoli în acest proces.
Amintește-ți că gate-urile Toffoli sunt gate-uri controlled-controlled-NOT, deci acțiunea lor pe stările bazei standard
este cum vezi aici pe ecran.
Observă că putem de asemenea
gândi la gate-urile Toffoli ca la gate-uri de interogare
pentru funcția AND.
Asta nu înseamnă că ele sunt gate-uri de interogare în sens literal. Cum am menționat la începutul lecției, nu lucrăm în cadrul
modelului de interogare în acest punct,
ci mai degrabă, acțiunea lor urmează același tipar ca un gate de interogare.
Putem gândi valorile binare A și B ca intrările funcției AND și, ca un gate de interogare,
aceste valori sunt ecouate
ca parte a ieșirii și valoarea funcției, adică AND-ul logic al lui A și B
se XOR-ează pe qubit-ul de jos. Acum, nu am inclus gate-urile Toffoli în setul nostru standard de gate-uri.
Am putea să ne răzgândim dacă am vrea, dar nu avem cu adevărat nevoie să
facem asta deoarece alternativ, putem implementa gate-uri Toffoli folosind gate-uri Hadamard,
gate-uri T și T dagger
și gate-uri NOT controlate cum vezi chiar aici.
Nu este deloc evident
că acel circuit particular implementează un gate Toffoli, dar o face și poți fie să mă crezi pe cuvânt
fie să înmulțești totul tu însuți pentru ceva practică suplimentară, sau poți pur și simplu să ceri Qiskit sau Python
sau orice software care înmulțește matrice să facă înmulțirea pentru tine.
Și poți consulta
conținutul manualului pentru lecție pentru a vedea cum se face asta folosind Qiskit.
Acum putem trece la simularea gate-urilor Boolean cu circuit-uri cuantice și tot ce vom avea nevoie pentru asta sunt gate-uri NOT,
gate-uri NOT controlate și gate-uri Toffoli.
Aceste operații sunt toate deterministe pe lângă faptul că sunt unitare și uneori descriem
operații ca acestea ca reversibile și, de fapt,
studiul computației reversibile precede computația cuantică și de acolo provine întreaga
această procedură.
Gate-urile Boolean de care trebuie să ne
îngrijorăm sunt gate-urile NOT, gate-urile Hadamard și gate-urile FANOUT,
Și ceea ce vom arăta este că putem implementa aceste gate-uri sau simula dacă
preferi, folosind gate-uri NOT,
gate-uri NOT controlate și gate-uri Toffoli.
Pentru a fi clar, ce
vrem sunt circuit-uri cuantice care să ne permită să calculăm valorile gate-urilor Boolean pe care tocmai le-am menționat
când le oferim qubit-uri în
stări ale bazei standard ca intrare.
Pentru intrări arbitrare de stări cuantice, acțiunea va fi determinată
de liniaritate ca de obicei.
Nu trebuie să facem nimic
special cu gate-urile NOT. Gate-urile NOT sunt gate-uri NOT și pot fi implementate direct.
Și gate-urile OR pot fi simulate
folosind gate-uri Toffoli și NOT.
Gate-urile AND sunt ușoare, mai ales în lumina a ceea ce tocmai am spus cu câteva momente în urmă despre gate-urile Toffoli ca implementări esențiale
de gate de interogare
ale funcției AND.
Mai precis, ceea ce putem face este să introducem un nou qubit inițializat în starea zero
și să lăsăm acel qubit să fie
ținta gate-ului nostru Toffoli și să lăsăm cei doi qubit-uri de intrare
să fie controalele.
Se dau diferite nume
qubit-urilor suplimentare ca acestea, care sunt adesea introduse
în computațiile cuantice și le voi numi qubit-uri de spațiu de lucru doar ca să aleg un nume.
WEBVTT
Presupunerea noastră tipică despre qubit-urile de spațiu de lucru este că pornesc în starea zero și adesea le putem returna
în starea zero
când am terminat cu ele, dar nu întotdeauna.
În diagramă avem un ket zero în interiorul dreptunghiului punctat pentru a indica că
inițializarea acestui qubit
face parte din proces și dacă nu ai
un qubit proaspăt ca acesta, nu vei putea
face această simulare.
Qubit-ul de ieșire de jos
este cel care ne interesează deoarece acela este rezultatul
operației AND și am terminat practic cu celelalte două
deci pot rămâne în interiorul casetei.
De fapt, ai putea chiar să-ți imaginezi că eliminarea acestor două qubit-uri face parte din sarcina
simulării acestui gate AND,
cam ca niște deșeuri care
trebuie curățate.
Dar oricum, acesta este modul în care putem
simula un gate AND.
Acum că știm cum să facem gate-uri AND, putem face gate-uri OR folosind
una din legile lui De Morgan.
Dacă pui gate-uri NOT pe cele două intrări și pe ieșirea unui gate AND,
vei obține un gate OR, deci este atât de simplu.
Și ultimul este FANOUT și pentru acesta, tot ce
avem nevoie este un gate NOT controlat împreună cu un qubit de spațiu de lucru.
Mai specific, dacă
setăm qubit-ul de spațiu de lucru ca țintă, copiăm efectiv orice stare a bazei standard care intră,
deci aceasta acționează ca un gate FANOUT.
Deci avem toate gate-urile noastre.
Și acum că avem toate gate-urile noastre, putem trece la circuit-uri.
Să presupunem că avem
un circuit Boolean numit C și acesta poate fi orice
circuit Boolean ai alege
atâta timp cât este compus din
gate-uri AND sau NOT și FANOUT.
Vom lăsa T să fie numărul de gate-uri din C și vom da numele F funcției pe care C o calculează.
Deci ne putem gândi la F ca având forma pe care o vezi chiar aici, unde N este numărul de biți de intrare ai lui C,
M este numărul de biți de ieșire și sigma este alfabetul binar.
Și ceea ce facem este să parcurgem pur și simplu gate-urile lui C unul câte unul.
Lăsăm gate-urile NOT neschimbate și le înlocuim pe celelalte cu simulările
pe care tocmai le-am descris.
Deci, dacă C arată astfel, atunci ceea ce obținem este un circuit
R care arată astfel.
În această diagramă, toți
qubit-urile de spațiu de lucru de care avem nevoie pentru simulări au fost scoși din casetele lor și colectați în jos.
Deci K este numărul total de
qubit-uri de spațiu de lucru de care avem nevoie, care este unul pentru fiecare gate al lui C cu excepția gate-urilor NOT.
Pentru ieșirea lui R, avem qubit-urile care
corespund ieșirii lui C și, aici, acele qubit-uri
sunt reprezentate în sus,
deși nu va conta cu adevărat la finalul tuturor acestora
dacă sunt deasupra sau nu.
Mai precis, presupunând că am rulat R pe o stare a bazei standard corespunzând unui
șir arbitrar de N biți X,
aceste M qubit-uri de ieșire vor fi în starea bazei standard
corespunzând lui F de X.
Avem de asemenea toate qubit-urile rămase de la gate-urile AND și OR.
Încă trebuie să le luăm în considerare și dacă le adunăm pe toate împreună, vor fi într-o anumită stare a bazei standard.
Oricare ar fi starea bazei standard, trebuie să fie o funcție a șirului X și vom da
acea funcție numele G.
Deci G este o nouă funcție care este
determinată de gate-urile lui C, care ne spune în ce stare
sunt acești qubit-uri rămași
după ce R este rulat. G este litera de după F, deci acesta este un motiv pentru a
numi această funcție G,
dar un alt motiv pentru a o numi G este că G este prescurtarea pentru garbage (deșeuri).
Toți aceștia sunt qubit-uri de deșeuri și, în particular, avem
doi qubit-uri de deșeuri pentru fiecare gate AND și pentru fiecare gate OR.
Numărul total de gate-uri
de care avem nevoie este big-O din T.
Asta deoarece pentru fiecare gate al lui C, avem nevoie de un număr limitat de gate-uri cuantice.
Gate-ul OR este cel mai costisitor. Pentru acela, avem nevoie de trei gate-uri NOT împreună cu un gate Toffoli,
iar un gate Toffoli ne costă 15 gate-uri din setul nostru standard de gate-uri.
Deci sunt cel mult 18 gate-uri
în R pentru fiecare gate al lui C.
Dacă ai vrea să optimizezi asta, ai putea, dar în scopurile unei
analize asimptotice grosiere, putem spune pur și simplu că
R are big-O din T gate-uri.
Deci am reușit să
calculăm aceeași funcție F pe care o calcula circuitul Boolean original C,
și am făcut asta la un cost care este liniar în dimensiunea lui C.
Dacă tot ce ne interesează este
calcularea acestei funcții F, atunci am terminat.
Dar, din păcate, avem
acești qubit-uri de deșeuri și acești qubit-uri de deșeuri
vor ruina în general
tiparele de interferență care fac algoritmii cuantici să funcționeze dacă încercăm să folosim
acest circuit R ca subrutină
în cadrul unui algoritm cuantic mai mare.
Dar putem de fapt să
scăpăm de aceste deșeuri și modul în care putem face
asta este să folosim faptul că circuitul R poate fi inversat,
WEBVTT
sau cu alte cuvinte, îl
putem rula în sens invers.
Pentru a ilustra cum funcționează asta, să ne imaginăm că mai întâi rulăm R și apoi rulăm R în sens invers,
ceea ce putem exprima ca R dagger.
Pentru a fi clar despre asta, ceea ce înseamnă este că aplicăm gate-urile
lui R în ordine inversă și luăm inversele
fiecărui gate.
Gate-urile NOT, gate-urile NOT controlate
și gate-urile Toffoli sunt de fapt propriile lor inverse, deci dacă ne gândim în termenii acestor gate-uri,
R dagger este de fapt R cu gate-urile furnizate
în ordine inversă.
Dar în general, putem întotdeauna rula orice circuit cuantic unitar în sens invers în modul în care tocmai l-am descris,
adică aplicăm
gate-urile în ordine inversă și înlocuim fiecare
gate individual cu inversul său.
Dacă am face asta, am găsi că mai întâi rularea lui R și apoi rularea lui R în
sens invers nu face nimic.
Deci, dacă am pornit dintr-o stare a bazei standard cum avem aici, atunci am termina exact în aceeași stare a bazei standard.
Desigur, a face doar
asta nu este foarte util, dar ceea ce putem face este să introducem o serie de qubit-uri suplimentare și mai specific,
aceștia sunt M qubit-uri unde M este numărul de biți de ieșire ai circuitului C.
Acești qubit-uri suplimentari ar putea
fi în orice stare cuantică, dar pentru a explica cum funcționează asta, vom presupune că sunt într-o stare a bazei standard
corespunzând unui șir Y. Deci Y este un șir de M biți și ceea ce putem face este să efectuăm
o serie de gate-uri NOT controlate
cum le vezi chiar aici, care XOR-ează efectiv șirul F de X
peste șirul Y stocat
în acești M qubit-uri de jos.
Și deci ieșirea
întregii computații este cum apare pe ecran.
X și Y sunt șiruri binare arbitrare. X are M biți și Y are M biți și de asemenea avem nevoie de K qubit-uri de spațiu de lucru.
Când rulăm R, calculăm F de X și acel șir este stocat
în primii M qubit-uri de sus, dar avem și o serie de qubit-uri de deșeuri,
deci XOR-ăm ieșirea F de
X pe M qubit-urile de jos și apoi rulăm R în sens invers
pentru a curăța deșeurile.
Trebuie să subliniez că este important ca R să fie determinist.
Dacă acești M qubit-uri de sus ar putea fi în schimb în o anumită superpozițe de
stări ale bazei standard, asta nu ar funcționa corect,
dar aceasta funcționează când
R este determinist.
Deci, dacă comparăm circuitul cuantic
pe care tocmai l-am construit cu circuitul Boolean original C, vedem că funcționează practic
în același mod
ca un gate de interogare funcționează
pentru o funcție arbitrară.
Există o diferență aici, care este că avem nevoie de
acești qubit-uri de spațiu de lucru pentru a face totul să funcționeze, dar altfel am
construit efectiv un gate de interogare
sau un circuit de interogare pentru orice funcție pe care C o calculează.
Am reușit de asemenea, apropo, să returnăm qubit-urile de spațiu de lucru
la starea lor inițială, deci ar putea fi în principiu reutilizate
ca qubit-uri de spațiu de lucru pentru
computații ulterioare.
Dacă vrem, putem pune o casetă în jurul întregului circuit cuantic și îl putem numi Q și relația cu
C devine mai clară.
Circuitul Q va fi
mai mare decât C în general. Avem nevoie de câteva gate-uri cuantice în Q pentru fiecare gate al lui C,
și de asemenea avem nevoie de gate-urile NOT controlate
din mijloc, dar numărul este totuși
liniar în dimensiunea lui C.
Trebuie de asemenea notat că aceasta este o procedură complet generală care funcționează pentru orice circuit Boolean și nu am încercat deloc să optimizăm Q.
Pentru un circuit specific C, ar putea exista foarte bine
modalități de a reduce dimensiunea lui Q și aceasta include utilizarea metodelor
care reduc numărul de
qubit-uri de spațiu de lucru necesare în cazul în care aceasta este ceva
ce vrem să facem și aceasta este procedura pentru rularea
computațiilor clasice
pe un calculator cuantic.
Este destul de simplă, dar este un lucru important
de putut face.
În particular, acum că
știm cum să facem asta, suntem liberi să folosim orice computații clasice vrem
în cadrul computațiilor cuantice, cu condiția că urmăm această formă unde intrarea este ecoată și ieșirea este XOR-ată
pe o serie de qubit-uri
la fel cum am avut pentru gate-urile de interogare.
Costul scalează liniar. Deci, de exemplu, putem
crea circuit-uri cuantice pentru probleme ca adunarea întreagă,
înmulțire, împărțire, calcularea CMMDC-urilor și exponențierea modulară și toate acestea pot fi făcute la același cost asimptotic
ca pentru circuit-urile Boolean.
Avem nevoie de qubit-uri de spațiu de lucru pentru a face asta, dar cel puțin sunt disponibile pentru a fi reutilizate din nou când
am terminat cu ele.
O ultimă remarcă care merită menționată este că această metodă ne oferă o metodă pentru a implementa gate-uri de interogare,
la care am făcut aluzie în lecția anterioară.
Adică, dacă avem un algoritm de interogare care ia o funcție F ca intrare și avem o modalitate de a calcula
F cu un circuit Boolean,
atunci putem urma această procedură pentru a construi un gate de interogare pentru acea funcție și apoi rula algoritmul nostru de interogare pe ea.
Dacă asta este un lucru util de făcut depinde de problema de interogare în sine și de ce încercăm să realizăm, dar în esență, această
construcție ne oferă
o modalitate de a conecta modelul de interogare la un model de computație mai standard.
Aceasta este, în un anumit sens, cum funcționează algoritmul lui Shor pentru factorizarea întreagă.
WEBVTT
Vom construi
circuit-uri cuantice ca acestea din unele dintre operațiile aritmetice despre care am vorbit mai devreme în lecție.
Și făcând asta,
oferim circuit-urilor cuantice capacitatea de a evalua acele operații pe superpozițe de stări clasice.
Și cum vom vedea, asta ne permite să factorizăm numerele întregi eficient.
Aceasta este sfârșitul acestei lecții, care s-a concentrat în principal pe stabilirea unei fundații
pentru algoritmii cuantici într-un cadru computațional standard non-cutie neagră.
Am vorbit despre costul computațional în principal prin prisma problemelor legate de teoria de bază a numerelor.
Am discutat costul polinomial
față de cel exponențial pentru sarcinile computaționale și am văzut cum computațiile clasice
pot fi implementate de circuit-urile cuantice într-un mod curat fără deșeuri care le permite să fie folosite ca subrutine
în cadrul unor computații cuantice mai mari.
Sper că te vei alătura mie la lecția următoare unde vom vedea cum algoritmul lui Shor pune aceste idei în practică, permițându-ne să factorizăm
numerele întregi la cost polinomial.
La revedere până atunci.